There are other ways of drawing with the canvas as well and
I'm going to go ahead and demonstrate one right here.
It begins with this command,
BeginPath which we're calling on the context of the campus.
BeginPath tells the canvas that we're about to draw a new shape.
Then we use this command MoveTo.
Now with moveTo and LineTo it makes actually a lot of sense to
think about a pen actually moving on page.
MoveTo moves a pen to a specific location on the canvas which is designated by
the x and y coordinate here.
So this command moves the pen to 10, 10 which is going to be about right here.
You can think of move to as just moving the pen but
the pen isn't making a mark yet.
We're just deciding where we want to put it down on the page.
But then when we call LineTo we actually put the pen down.
And make his mark or in this case align to this position.
So this line here with MoveTo 10,10.
Moves the pen or hovers it over 10,10.
Then when we call LineTo, we put the pen down and
then move it to the position of 50, 50.
Then we move it again and move it again.
If we refresh the page we'll see that there's nothing there
despite the fact that it looks like we made a shape that eventually goes back to
where we started at 10, 10.
That's because we need to call either a fill or
a stroke command to finish up this path.
Let's start by doing fill.
I will go ahead and uncomment this line and save, come over here and
hit Refresh.
And we see that we create a filled shape.
This made a triangle, so now we see a filled in triangle.
If we comment in fill and then un-comment stroke, let's see what happens.
We'll save.
Come over here and
hit Refresh and now we see a stroke triangle that's not filled in.
There are many other drawing commands that you can use in the canvas and
check out the link in the instructor notes if you want to learn more about them.
But most of them behave similarly to what we see here.
For this quiz we want you to recreate the shape that you
see here with the canvas.
I've gone ahead and
marked a few points on the outside square and the inside triangle.
This should make your life a little bit easier as you try to recreate it.
After you've finished it, check this box to continue.